paul ronzheimer du bist für uns
weiterhin in der hauptstadt caracas wies
die aktuelle lage es war die bislang
heftigste nacht die hauptstadt von
eckhard hier seit beginn des krieges
erlebt hat das haben uns auch anwohner
bestätigt mit denen wir heute im keller
uns versteckt haben zusammen mit anderen
das sind dramatische situation die man
da erlebt man hört die sirenen man sieht
die angst in den gesichtern der menschen
man sieht tränen und viele sind schier
verzweifelt hier hinter mir sieht man
wie massiv das ausmaß der zerstörung ist
wenn die bomben runterkommen
der japanischen armee unterstützt von
der türkei
das sind heftige zerstörungen das sind
sehr sehr starke waffen die dort zum
einsatz kommen
und gestern nacht hat es wieder
verletzte und auch tote gegeben
wir sehen sie als abidjan und armenien
sind im krieg warum denn der krieg der
konflikt um berg-karabach ist
tatsächlich kompliziert man muss sich
vorstellen
das sind gerade mal 125.000 einwohner
die hier wohnen aber der konflikt
schwelt schon seit zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion der erste große krieg den
gab es 1992 und aserbaidschan beruft
sich darauf dass völkerrechtlich diese
region zu aserbaidschan gehört
allerdings ist sie hauptsächlich von
armeniern besiedelt und die armenier
wollen das gebiet nicht hergeben jetzt
macht dieser krieg ist noch einmal
komplizierter weil aserbaidschan von der
türkei unterstützt wird von erdogan und
es gibt dort massive
auseinandersetzungen politischer natur
hauch zwischen armenien und der türkei
durch diese unterstützung aserbaidschans
wird das ganze möglicherweise auch zu
einem stellvertreterkrieg der weiter
auswachsen könnte und das macht die
sache so gefährlich paul nimmst du
forderungen an die deutsche regierung
war
die menschen wünschen sich vor allem
aufmerksamkeit dass deutschland
hinschaut das berichtet wird so wie wir
es jetzt gerade tun
aber auch von der politik wir wissen
dass staatspräsident makro und
frankreich zum beispiel klar gesagt hat
aserbaidschan hat diesen krieg begonnen
das wünschen sich die von den armeen
wünschen sich die armeen ja auch von
merkel dass sie das klar macht und was
mag
auch getan hat er da auf die
unterstützung der türkei und auf die
syrischen soldaten gewiesen hat diese
aussagen gab es bislang auch noch nicht
von deutschland also im vergleich zu
frankreich ist deutschland das sehr
diplomatisch und das sieht man hier eher
kritisch wir sind bild und wir liefern
dir deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren